benjamin lucas porte-parole porte-parole
de générations et gilles casanova
consultant en stratégie et communication
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france benjamins lucas
vous allez vous allez adopter cette
motion de censure on a entendu le chef
de file de la france est soumise en
parler est ce que vous en tant que
socialiste en tout cas vous vous êtes
d'accord sur cette motion de censure
coûté oui il faut répondre à ce qui est
aujourd'hui un bras d'honneur du
gouvernement à notre démocratie un bras
d'honneur d'une extraordinaire brutalité
parce qu'enfin d'habitude le 49-3 il est
utilisé pour quoi d'habitude il est
utilisé parce qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité là il ya une majorité on l'a vu
une majorité pour voter ce texte
simplement le gouvernement veut
s'extraire du débat parlementaire et là
où les français ne demandez pas
d'accélérer mais de ralentir le
gouvernement décide de patte de passer
en force avec une grande brutalité
vraiment je dis c'est un bras d'honneur
qui est fait qu'ils aient fait notre
démocratie parce que on ne piétine pas
la protection sociale qui s'est
construite par deux siècles de patientes
négociations de combats sociaux on ne
détruit pas la protection sociale et de
retraite en deux semaines à la va-vite
en pleine crise sanitaire et à deux
semaines des élections municipales c'est
le timing qui crée la panique on l'a vu
à l'assemblée nationale tout le monde et
est venu en urgence en tout cas pour
réagir pourquoi ce jour aujourd'hui
gilles casanova c'est vrai qu'il était
question de discuter du coronavirus et
le 49-3 qui est brandi en fin d'après
midi on s'y attendait quoi qu'il arrive
mais pourquoi aujourd'hui et pourquoi
cette surprise nous sommes dans une
situation inédite même en mai 1968
l'exécutif n'était pas aussi isolé les
centres villes étaient en ébullition une
douzaine de millions de salariés étaient
en grève
il y avait 50 millions de français est
donc 38 qu'ils n'étaient pas les
élections suivantes on pouvait
l'isolément des centres villes là ce
n'est plus du tout le cas
les centres villes sont mobilisés sur la
question des retraites 75% des français
n'y sont pas favorables
les salariés sont beaucoup plus nombreux
qui lie à 60 ans qu'il ya 50 ans pardon
et
sont très hostiles beaucoup plus encore
que la moyenne des français
les îles et jaune qui représente les
campagnes sont aussi un mouvement qui
isole ce gouvernement donc dans cet
isolement
quelle était la porte de sortie le
coronavirus et la porte de sortie
il permet d'interdire les rassemblements
il permettra peut-être demain disent
certains députés de la majorité de
repousser les élections municipales qui
s'annonce comme extrêmement difficile
pour le parti majoritaire
et c'est à l'issue d'un conseil des
ministres qui a évoqué un conseil
extraordinaire qui a évoqué toutes les
mesures exceptionnelles et exorbitante
du droit commun qui pourraient être
prises à l'occasion de l'épidémie de
coronavirus que le gouvernement conclut
de passer sans vote ni débat par le 49-3
on voit bien qu'il y a là une tentative
de sortir au dernier moment quand une
porte se referme serein mais dans un
métro ou un train et qu'on veut passer
au dernier moment alors le gouvernement
met en cause aussi ces amendements a
déposé par milliers tout justement pour
bloquer cette réforme absolument qui est
présenté par edouard philippe en tout
cas comme c'est toujours le cas dont les
grandes réformes et les parties dont il
était membre
avant de découvrir qu emmanuel macron
existait pouvait devenir président avait
joué à cela alternativement les uns et
les autres
quand il était dans l'opposition ça n'a
aucun caractère de nouveauté tous les
gouvernements ça et les dirigeants du
groupe parlementaire majoritaire savent
comment gérer ces questions là il y a
quelque chose de particulier c'est que
le conseil d'état indiqué que cette
réforme
t'es pas présentés dans des conditions
qui permettait qu'elle soit sûre
juridiquement ce qui veut dire que healy
a toutes chances que le conseil
constitutionnel l'a retoquée et la re
top profondément le calcul de l'exécuter
fait probablement de dire le peu qu'il
en restera permettra de casser le
système actuel de façon à ce qu'il
faille bien en mettre en place un autre
et là nous aurons le temps de mettre en
place l'autre l'important est de casser
celui-ci benjamin lucas beaucoup
déplorent le manque de démocratie
finalement de l'acte
2ce 49 3 pourquoi vouloir aller si vite
pourquoi ne pas laisser le temps au
débat selon vous c'est incompréhensible
je le disais la protection sociale elle
s'est construite à travers deux siècles
de luttes de combat de négociation de
dialogue de grandes avancées
parlementaire et vouloir à ce rythme là
la casse et c'est incompréhensible
encore une fois le débat parlementaire
moi je le regardais oui et l'obstruction
parlementaire comme y en a toujours eu
gilles casanova l'a rappelé sur les sur
les grands textes qui ont été qui ont
été posées devant devant le parlement
moi je crois qu'il du coup il faudra une
réponse à la hauteur et que la réponse à
l'auteur c'est une motion de censure
électorale le 15 mars prochain il faudra
saisir partout nouveau des bulletins de
vote de la gauche et des écologistes
pour dire emmanuel macron que cela
suffit que nos concitoyens n'accepte pas
n'accepte pas d'être dépossédé d'un
débat sur leur avenir la retraite ça
concerne tout le monde c'est notre
patrimoine commun on ne peut pas comme
cela en force en catimini vouloir faire
passer cette réforme qui est rejetée je
le rappelle par plus de six français sur
dix après des mois et des mois de
mobilisation sociale comme on en a pas
vu dans ce pays depuis des années donc
là aussi on a vraiment un sujet qui nous
gouvernement foule au pied les la
démocratie contre elle en tchétchénie et
elle a été elle a été bâclée de l'avis
de tout le monde moi j'ai vu dans les
débats parlementaires le gouvernement
est incapable de répondre aux questions
de l'opposition sans doute pour cela
qu'il veut aller vite parce que plus le
débat avance plus nos concitoyens qui
sont déjà nombreux à être angoissé par
cette réforme à la refuser
on voit bien que le gouvernement est
incapable incapable de répondre sur des
points précis incapable de dire à chaque
française qui est calme le sujet qu'est
ce que nous allons perdre ou gagner dans
cette réforme
on voit bien qu'on va y perdre beaucoup
le gouvernement est incapable de dire
concrètement pour chaque situation
pour chaque cas pour des centaines de
professions pour des millions de
français
quelle va être la réalité concrète de
cette réforme et on ne peut pas
gouverner un pays en laissant dont
concitoyens dans l' angoisse de cette
façon alors on a entendu les
représentants et les républicains dire
d'autant qu' à la conférence de
financement qui se tient en ce moment
même en même temps et on n'a toujours
pas les réponses sur sur les conclusions
de
de cette conférence et le 49-3 qui est
qui et brandissant même attendre
finalement ces mesures de la part des
syndicats qui planchent sur la question
gilles casanova de toute façon cette
réforme n'est pas prête
telle qu'elle est le conseil d'état l'a
dit mais pas seulement lui cette réforme
elle n'est pas prête n'est pas
applicable
le texte présenté jusqu'ici est très
lacunaire
il ne permettrait pas une mise en oeuvre
son financement lui même n'est pas
assurée donc il ne peut pas permettre
une mise en oeuvre donc la question
elle n'est pas de faire adopter ce texte
en positif la question elle est de faire
de poser un acte fort pour dire qu'on ne
reviendra pas en arrière mais il
apparaît bien difficile de garantir
qu'il n'y aura pas de retour en arrière
d'autant que le 49-3 a un double effet
le premier effet c'est de discréditer
celui qu'il utilise la dernière personne
qui a en conseil des ministres donnés au
premier ministre son approbation pour le
49 3 et françois hollande c'était pour
une loi rédigée sous l'influencé des
manuels macro loi travail aloi travail
françois hollande n'a pas été en mesure
de se représenter à la suite de cela on
peut penser là que le gouvernement fait
un pari extrêmement risqué alors il a un
effet secondaire qui peut l'intéresser
qui est que devant le blocage du débat
parlementaire du vote parlementaire
l'interdiction prochaine des
manifestations au nom du coronavirus
peut-être ce sera l'argument présentait
et eric la suspension des travaux du
parlement à l'occasion du corps d'un
virus peut être le report des élections
municipales à l'occasion du cros navires
us
l'addition de tout cela peut conduire
une partie des opposants au gouvernement
à se tourner vers des actions violentes
qui donc permettrait une rhétorique sur
l'idée que critiquer le gouvernement
c'est tomber dans la violence
c'est tout de même un peu risqué on note
que la dernière fois que le gouvernement
a tenté cela il y a maintenant un an
une étude a montré que 34% des français
n'était pas choqué par l'utilisation de
la violence
ce qui n'a jamais été atteint un niveau
aussi élevé en france dans des études
d'opinion on va écouter gilles legendre
et un laurent à petra chiefs qui
justement kyo évidemment ont soutenu de
cette majorité qui a soutenu le 49-3
évidemment écoutez il ya des oppositions
qui s'expriment il est aussi une
majorité cette majorité souhaitaient
avancer puis d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs
oppositions
vous avez bien lu que les oppositions
notamment des républicains et du parti
socialiste de liberté les territoires
étaient empêchés d'avoir ce débat sur le
fond il aurait souhaité avoir ce débat
sur le fond elles ont été empêchées
parce que nous faisions des débats à
n'en plus finir sur des amendements de
synonymes
je pense que il faut abandonner pouvoir
aussi avancé dans le texte dans le débat
c'est l'objet de cette décision du
premier ministre d'engagement de
responsabilité que l'on puisse continuer
à avancer on puisse permettre aux textes
de faire ce chemin parlementaire qu'il a
à faire à la fois parce que le projet de
texte sur lequel la responsabilité
également été engagée dans un projet
largement amendé par l'ensemble des
députés vous verrez qu'il y a des
éléments qui devaient aussi les
oppositions et puis aussi parce qu'il y
aura à la fois le temps du sénat depuis
longtemps la deuxième lecture
donc il faut aussi permettre que ce
texte vivre sa ville sa vie
parlementaire
c'est l'objet de cette décision tout
sommes dans un cas absolument inédit
d'une obstruction délibérée mener par 33
députés qui ont décidé dès le premier
jour de débat de faire en sorte que le
travail des 544 autres ne puissent pas
se dérouler normalement
il n'avait qu'un objectif qui n'était
pas d'amender le texte qui est un droit
irréductibles de tous les parlementaires
opposition et majorité il n'avait qu'un
objectif c'est de faire en sorte que ce
texte ne voit pas le jour
nous avions dit que nous avions prévu
d'y consacrer deux semaines
nous en avons compte nous avons consacré
un nombre d'heures inouïe près de 115
heures ce qui nous amène tout près des
records sauf que les records de durée
amener au vote du texte c'est la
première fois que autant de temps est
consacré un texte pour qu'une toute
petite partie de ces articles 8 articles
sur 65 plus être adopté dans notre
réaction d'un malgache
oui bon à la brutalité sociale de cette
réforme injuste le gouvernement ajoute
ajoute la brutalité démocratique et ce
49 3 sur monsieur legendre quelle
méconnaissance de notre histoire et
l'histoire parlementaire je sais bien
qu'ils sont ils considèrent les
maquereaux ni ce qu'ils ont tout tenté
avec de vraies connaissances honnêtement
toutes les grandes lois dans ce pays et
même des moins importante elles se sont
faites par le débat parlementaire et
c'est normal dans une démocratie que
l'on prenne du temps et que l'opposition
elle s'oppose on ne fera croire à
personne que c'est l'opposition qui
dicte ses décisions à la majorité donc
on voit bien le gouvernement avait
choisi depuis plusieurs jours d'ailleurs
ça se passait plutôt bien
nous avons un député régis juanico qui a
posé des questions auxquelles il n'a pas
eu de réponse qui a porté un certain
nombre d'amendements de propositions qui
a évoqué des situations très précises
pour lesquelles il n'y a pas eu de
réponses du gouvernement et de la
majorité
on voit bien que en fait ce qui bloque
ce qu'ils font de l'obstruction
démocratique aujourd'hui c'est le
gouvernement et emmanuel macron ça
dénote quand même d'un grand risque pour
notre démocratie parce que ça a été dit
mais le risque c'est qu'on se retourne
vers la violence vers la radicalité
qu'on ne puisse plus dans ce pays et
avoir des débats démocratiques c'est ce
qui s'est passé est grave et très
inquiétant pour notre démocratie
parlementaire n'a écouté on a entendu le
secrétaire d'état aux retraites
justement diront poids quand même à
lancer dans le débat c'est c'est vrai on
pourra avancer dans des vagues gilles
casanova malgré le 49-3 pas du tout le
49 3 c'est un passage sans débat et sans
vote ou bien le texte tel qu'il est
présenté laon 49,3 n'est pas le même non
plus qu'il y avait quelques semaines
c'est le texte du gouvernement tel que
le gouvernement entend le présenter il
n'y a pas de vote sur ce texte ce texte
est adopté
sauf si une motion de censure est
adoptée qui renverse le gouvernement
donc ou bien on renverse le gouvernement
ou bien ce texte est adopté sans un seul
mot sans un seul caractère de
modification c'est ça le système du 49-3
qui ferme la porte
quant à monsieur legendre effectivement
il est dans le nouveau monde mais ce
nouveau monde
il se referme définitivement avec le
49-3 qui est terriblement ancien monde
et si nous regardons l'ancien monde
on voit que des semaines de débats ont
été nécessaires pour l'adoption du texte
de loi sur le mariage pour tous qui
comprenait un nombre de lignes
extrêmement limitée et qui a duré
plusieurs semaines
c'est la tradition française du débat
parlementaire alors on peut craindre
qu'il y ait ce sentiment que la
démocratie c'est embarrassant cet
ennuyeux
ça fait perdre du temps et puis c'est
désagréable parce que les gens qui sont
en désaccord avec l'exécutif ont de
mauvaises idées
alors ça dans l'histoire on a connu ça
assez souvent
en général ça ne conduit pas à des
conclusions favorables
benjamin lucas les motions de censure il
ya plusieurs sons seront pas d une
solution à son épouse et par différents
partis ça a une chance d'aboutir selon
vous mais non la majorité est un genre
la majorité majoritaire mais il faut que
les oppositions qui puisse le faire et
qu'elles saisissent tous les outils
constitutionnels leur disposition et je
dis à nos concitoyens qui nous regardent
qu'ils auront une motion de censure
électorale dès le 15 mars prochain le
premier tour des élections municipales
d'abord dans l'évolution qui était dès
le premier tour d'élections municipales
en saisissant des bulletins de vote de
la gauche et des écologistes pour pour
dire stop à emmanuel macron et pour
revenir sur ce qu'on disait quand même
dans les arguments qui ont été employés
vous l'avez dit sur sur ce qu'on remet
en cause dans la démocratie il ya même
un parlementaire la majorité qui a dit
ça coûte de l'argent de réunir
l'assemblée nationale ça coûte de
l'argent de débattre d'un texte mais où
on va parce que ça coûte de l'argent
aussi les élections la démocratie ça
coûte de l'argent
quand on a ce genre de raisonnement là
on voit bien qu'il ya dans le maquereau
nice mais finalement est un défi posé à
la démocratie il ya dans le maquereau
nisme refus de la démocratie de la
tradition démocratique française et des
grandes démocraties que nous connaissons
il ya à mon avis quelque chose de très
dangereux de traits période pour notre
république
gilles casanova on avait vu déjà la
grogne des gilet jaune là c'est reparti
c'est quelque chose qui a mis le feu aux
poudres finalement ce 49 3 on peut
penser que les choses ne vont pas
s'arrêter là
on peut penser que toutes les mesures de
restriction des libertés publiques qui
vont être liés aux coronavirus risque de
faire durer dans la dans le temps ce
mouvement même si elles peuvent conduire
à ce qu'ils ne s'expriment pas
publiquement par des manifestations de
masse si elles sont interdites et si
l'épidémie semble progresser il faut
quand même noter que plusieurs milliers
de personnes sont déjà mortes de la
grippe dans ce pays depuis le début de
l'année et que on ne s'en inquiète pas
autant que de quelques les chiffres
réels de la grippe classique peut-être
que ce serait même plus alarmant que par
la grêle issifou la grippe classique
dépasse en général les dix mille morts
par hiver mais donc nous avons une
situation qui annonce la continuation
d'un mouvement de protestation de longue
durée et qui trouvera à un moment ou à
un autre car je vois mal qu'on annule
l'élection présidentielle pour
coronavirus alors là on a le temps une
expression expression qui risque de
faire sauter tous les plafonds de verre
connu jusqu'ici à la grogne heures en
tout cas s'exprime on l'entend ce soir
benjamin lucas
pourquoi le gouvernement n'entend pas
finalement ce qui se passe dans la rue
on a eu toutes ces manifestations vous
l'avez dit depuis le 5 décembre dernier
contre la réforme des retraites en
brandissant à 49,3 le gouvernement
savait ce à quoi s'attendre en tout cas
en terme de gras une social je crois que
tout ça est une stratégie de la part d'
emmanuel macron c'est pas ce n'est pas
laissé au hasard c'est emmanuel macron
veut un affrontement dans le pays le
créé de la tension
par ses provocations par le duel du haut
qu'il met en scène depuis la dernière
élection présidentielle avec madame le
pen et finalement c'est ce qu'il veut
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui n'a rien
fait pour apaiser un pays en tension n'a
rien fait pour apporter des réponses aux
problématiques légitimes exprimées par
les jets des jaunes pendant presque deux
ans il n'est aujourd'hui pas dans le
rôle d'un président de la république il
est il se comporte comme un chef de clan
qui aujourd'hui agite agit de sa base
qui créent de l'affrontement de la
tension dans le pays
et encore une fois c'est très dangereux
parce que moi vous savez je pense qu'on
peut être nous sommes d'une grande
démocratie un peuple très politique on
aime bien débattre on peut ne pas être
d'accord et ça nous arrive est un
gouvernement qui a gagné les élections
il est légitime qu'il mène sa politique
n'est là on n'est pas dans un débat
démocratique normal est serein on est
dans une volonté de monter en épingle un
affrontement et tout ça peut très mal
tourner moi j'appelle le président de la
république a retrouvé de la raison et à
se comporter en fin au président de la
république soucieux d'apaiser son pays
merci benjamin lucas merci également aux
îles casanova on va retrouver tout de
suite notre reporter sur place devant
l'assemblée nationale pierre pissavy
yvernault pierre vous êtes parmi elles
les manifestants ce soir quelle est
l'ambiance
eh bien écoutez magali une toute autre
ambiance un cas c'est qu'on a connu à
l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure
c'est beaucoup moins calme ici des à 18
heures des dizaines tout d'abord de
manifestants se sont réunis sur ce pont
de la concorde loyer derrière moi juste
en face de l'assemblée nationale ils ont
tp ensuite à des centaines et maintenant
des mines et je vous propose de regarder
justement les images de nicolas winckler
pourvoi est la foule qu'il ya ici ce
soir devant l'assemblée nationale
on voit de nombreux à drapeau notamment
des drapeaux de syndicats solidaires cgt
et d'autres nous avons croisé également
de nombreux gilet jaune qui ont
manifesté cet après-midi et qui sont là
encore une fois ce soit je vous disais
plusieurs milliers de personnes ici même
sur le pont de la concorde et la soirée
ne fait que commencer
merci beaucoup pierre pour toutes ces
précisions ont continué évidemment ce
débat sur le 49-3 qui a été déposée par
le premier ministre à 17h30 aujourd'hui
à la grande surprise de tous les partis
de l'opposition et des députés bien sûr
qu'ils étaient dans l'hémicycle en train
de débattre de la réforme des retraites
on va savez-vous finalement benjamin
lucas et et gilles casanova pour
continuer puisque les esprits ont
tendance à s'échauffer on vient de le
voir avec pierre pissavy yvernault
devant l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre est allé déposer ce 49,3 à
17h30 il y avait ça me débats sur le
coronavirus pour savoir quelles mesures
prendre pour faire face à cette épidémie
le fait de prendre pour argument le
coronavirus le timing pour vous était
judicieux gilles casanova c'est un coup
politique ce n'est pas un coup politique
à l'heure des réseaux sociaux à l'heure
de la transparence que ceux ci organise
ça aurait été un très bon coup politique
à la fin des années 50 mais dans le
nouveau monde
dans lequel nous sommes c'est à dire
celui où les réseaux sociaux en quelques
minutes permettent de rassembler les
gens permettent de donner les
informations permettent par exemple de
savoir qu'il y a plus de guérison du
coronavirus que de nouveaux cas le
corona virus depuis deux jours et donc
on peut se trouver comme pour la grippe
h1n1 devant un virus qui est
potentiellement terrifiant mais qui à la
fin ne réussit pas disons ne ressemble
pas à ce qui avait été imaginé et
apparemment ça n'a pas l'air d'effrayer
les français en tout cas les parisiens
puisqu'elles sont rassemblés devant
l'assemblée nationale ce soir on n'a pas
le chiffre exact on le connaîtra
évidemment un peu plus tard chiffres
officiels du ministère de l'intérieur on
le voit les crs sont déployés il ya du
monde tout de même devant cette
assemblée nationale et à l'intérieur
benjamin lucas les députés les députés
de la gauche viennent de déposer une
motion de censure donc ces motions qui
vont qui vont se succéder j'imagine la
nuit va être longue
selon vous oui mais l'année le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro et long
trop long c'est pour ça moi je souhaite
que la gauche et les écologistes qui
sont capables de se rassembler sur une
motion de censure soit capable de se
rassembler dans la perspective de
l'élection présidentielle parce qu'il
faudra tourner la page d' emmanuel
macron ont tourné aussi la page de cette
5ème république dont on voit qu'elle est
à bout de souffle le 49-3 n'a pas été
inventé par emmanuel macron il est une
arme redoutable qui mise entre les mains
d'apprentis sorciers de la démocratie
donne ce genre de résultat et de
brutalité donc il faudra que nous
tracions un autre chemin au delà de cet
épisode là qui est un épisode évidemment
révélateur de ce qui est notre vème
république et de ce qu'elle macro nisme
et dernière question avoue gilles cazade
nouvelle 49,3 vous l'avez déjà déjà été
utilisé pour la loi travail elle est
passée finalement cette loi il y avait
des manifestations dans la rue mais
finalement tout était rentré dans
l'ordre
tout n'est pas rentré dans l'ordre le
parti socialiste est passé de plus de 20
% à 6 %
d'un groupe parlementaire de près de 300
députés un groupe parlementaire de 30
députés
si vous dites politiques si vous êtes en
train de vous dire c'est cela alors
certes la loi est passée mais le parti
qui a mis le 49-3 s'est suicidé division
par 10 de son nombre d'élus divison
division par cinq de son score vous
voyez bien que c'est une arme
extraordinairement dangereuse
on peut imaginer que dans l'exécutif
tout le monde n'était pas sur cette idée
on peut imaginer que le président macro
est conçue que les castors c'est à dire
ce qu'ils veulent avant tout faire
barrage à marine le pen et qui votent
pour lui dès le premier tour pour faire
ce barrage se trouve à gauche et que si
on les affronte trop fortement le
passage du premier tour lui même va être
difficile mais edouard philippe
naguère le souci de faire réélire
monsieur macron c'est pas sa question
c'est pas son problème et lui pense que
au contraire c'est à droite qui a des
réserves pour faire un prochain
quinquennat et qu'il pourrait très bien
en être la tête de file on verra cela en
tout cas merci beaucoup et benjamins
lucas et merci gilles casanova est
revenu sur ce plateau pour nous parler
de ce 49 3